Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
so i'm continuing uh what we did yes uh last time which is talk about nibbana in that's that's the shortened that's the short and straight of it so here i'm just going to go through a discourse uh which is addressed by the buddha to a certain monk called kaivata and as we go through it you'll see what it's all about
so he says to Kavita there was a monk in this community of monks the sangha where a thought arose in his awareness where do these four great elements the earth property the liquid the liquid property that's that cohesive elasticity
the fire property that's heat and cold of course and the wind property that's movement or stillness or stiffness the earth property being heavy or light so where do they cease without remainder in other words where are they annihilated then he attained such a state of concentration that the way leading to the gods appeared in his focused mind
And so he approached the gods, and these seem to be the lowest of them, the retinue of the four great kings.
He said, friends, where do these four great elements, the earth element, liquid, fire, and wind element, cease without remainder?
When he had said this, they said to him, well, we also don't know where these four great elements cease without remainder.
but there are the four great kings themselves who are higher and more sublime so off he goes to try and find these four great kings and when he does they also say we also don't know where these four great elements come to an end cease without remainder so they suggest that he go a little higher to the gods of the 33
And when they arrive there, they also say, well, we don't know, but Saka, the ruler of the gods, who is higher and more sublime than we will know.
And in this way, they go up and up through the Yama gods and the Suyama gods and the Santusita gods and the Nimmanarati gods and the Sunamita gods.
So they're going higher and higher and they're all saying the same thing.
i don't know what it is but somebody upstairs knows better so you can see this is getting to be a bit of a satire and then finally the paranamita vasavati who was the chief of the paranamita gods said why don't you go and approach the retinue of brahma so when they when he approaches them he said they said of course well
We don't know, but Brahma himself will know.
So Brahma, of course, was the Vedic creator god.
And you can see here that it's beginning to be a bit of a satire on the way the Brahmins would believe or teach about these various gods, but especially the role of Brahma, who was the creator, the starter of all things, you see.
so this particular monk approaches Brahma and he also asks where do these four great elements cease without remainder and he meets this Brahma he says actually just going back a little bit he says that light shines forth and a radiance appears and Brahma will appear
but for these are the portents of Brahma's appearance light shines forth and a radiance appears so Brahma appears and the monk approaches the great Brahma and says friend where do these four great elements cease without remainder and the great Brahma replies
I, monk, am Brahma, the great Brahma, the conqueror, the unconquered, the all-seeing, the all-powerful, the sovereign Lord, maker, creator, chief, appointer, ruler, father of all that has been and shall be.
And the monk says to him, friend, I didn't ask you if you were Brahma, the great Brahma, the conqueror, the unconquered, and so on and so forth.
I asked you, where do the four great elements cease without remainder?
Well, poor old Brahma, he goes off again with his string of attributes.
I am Brahma, you know, the maker, creator, chief, appointer, ruler and so on.
So again, he asks him, you see, only this time, the great Brahma, taking the monk by the arm and leading him off to the side, said to him, these gods of the retinue of Brahma believe.
There is nothing that the great Brahma does not know.
There is nothing the great Brahma does not see.
There is nothing the great Brahma is unaware of.
There is nothing that the great Brahma has not realized.
That is why I did not say in their presence that I too don't know where the four great elements cease without remainder.
so you've acted wrongly you've acted incorrectly in bypassing the blessed one in search of an answer to this question elsewhere go right back to the blessed one and on arrival ask him this question however he answers it you should take it to heart and then because of his powers as a man might flex his arm he appears from the brahma world before the buddha
okay so so we've been all the way up through that all these higher heavens these sublime places uh and and he he just doesn't have an answer now when he comes back down interestingly enough the buddha says this to him once a monk some seafaring once monk some seafaring merchants took us a sure sighting bird and set sail in their ship when they could not see the shore
they released the shore-sighting bird.
It flew to the east, south, west, north, straight up, and to all the intermediate points of the compass.
If it saw the shore in any direction, it flew there.
If it did not see the shore in any direction, it returned back to the ship.
in the same way monk having gone as far as the brahma world in search of an answer to your question you have come right back to my presence so it sort of suggests that perhaps there were monks in the order monks and nuns monastics who were still as it were going for advice to the brahmins especially if they were brahmins themselves i don't know where it what it actually means but it's a it's an odd thing to admonish this poor monk
so anyway what he says to this monkey says your question should not be phrased in this way it should be where do these four great elements the earth element liquid element fire element and wind and a wind element cease without remainder instead it should be phrased like this where do earth water fire and air
find no footing where a long and short small and great fair and foul where our name and form body and mind brought to an end and the answer is this okay consciousness that is signless non-manifestive limitless without boundary and all illuminating in all directions full of light
there water earth fire and wind find no footing there long and short small and large pleasant and unpleasant there name and form body and mind have all been brought to an end with the cessation of consciousness all is brought to an end okay so now we have a problem
So the Buddha is a little bit like really any person who suddenly sees something which is beyond the culture, which is something which is new to the culture and they're always scrabbling for new words.
An obvious example would be Freud who had to come up with id, ego and superego to get across his model of the human mind.
so here he's using consciousness in two different ways okay so the first consciousness is the one that is going to cease is going to come to an end so this is the consciousness that the buddha describes by sense bases so there's eye consciousness there's ear consciousness nose consciousness mind heart consciousness okay so
This consciousness belongs to the five aggregates.
which are the body or our physicality all our feelings driven by both the body and emotions all our perceptions and the sankaras these habits of thought habits of actions which we remember create through an act of will and this consciousness so here this consciousness is like a screen upon which this information arises okay
That's the consciousness which disappears.
That's the consciousness which can experience these four great elements.
And he goes as far as to say that even the mind and the body also are brought to an end.
But this is not a final end.
It's where they find no footing.
And then he describes this experience, right, which has to be the experience of nirvana.
he says there's a consciousness so there's a knowing which is non-manifested the word that is nidassana cannot be seen so what cannot be seen what cannot be felt it stands for all the sense bases and it is limitless it doesn't have a boundary it's not dependent on anything and interestingly
It is all illuminating or in another translation, in all directions full of light.
And it is here that the earth, the fire, the wind and water elements find no footing.
so what we have here is again a restatement that there is a mundane experience that we have through this form of body and mind and there is something which sits within it but beyond it and when we experience what is beyond in its purity then what is mundane the body and mind do not appear and that really is
one of the most profound experiences of not-self because everything that we experience we tend to associate with either by way of identity or possession but here everything's gone and yet there remains this luminous consciousness and just as a reminder
going back to the early quotes of last month here he says there's a dimension where there's no earth no water no fire no wind so he's saying the same thing here but he's not so he's not actually telling us what it is he's telling us what's not there
He says no dimension of infinite space, infinite consciousness, nothingness, neither perception nor non-perception.
So there's none of those higher states of mind that we refer to as the jhāna, the absorptions.
There's not this world or another world.
There's no moon, no sun.
I say there's no coming or going, remaining or passing away or reappearing.
There's absolutely nothing there which is either phenomenal or physical.
and then we have this other quote which again tells us what's not there there is that which is unborn this is how it's translated unborn it's almost a direct translation unborn undying uncreated uncompounded which means it's unconditioned so there is something which was never born it doesn't it's never died it was never created doesn't develop
and is not bound by any conditions so we've had these statements now both of the negative what is not in nibbana but also this very positive statement about an experience that is nibbanic and this is only quoted twice within the whole of the scriptures
and it doesn't it doesn't appear in the udana disc in the udana collection which are a collection of his inspired verses so there's some filtering going on and just as a as an aside in the mahayana when buddhism so we say developed into the mahayana there was a school the yogachara school
that actually has a transcendent, that's what they call it, a transcendent Abhidhamma, and it's based upon this particular phrase, this particular verse that we've just been reading.
So this does not complete the mystery of Nibbana, unfortunately, and there's more to be said, and I'll find some time in order to talk about it.
So, I can only hope these words have been of self-assistance, that they have not caused confusion, and that by your careful investigation through your practice of Vipassana, you will attain this particular experience.
Sadhu, sadhu, sadhu.